we talk about safe sex what is really
meant the context is what's a safe way
to have random sex with strangers it's
impossible I don't care what kind of
contraception you're using that's never
going to be a safe thing to do that's
not a safe that is a high risk activity
no matter how you go about it you might
as well talk about what are safe ways to
drive drunk I suppose if you want to put
it this way there are safer ways to
drive drunk like if you're going to
drive drunk it's better to wear a seat
belt than not wear a seat belt and a
helmet and drive drunk you're gonna be
better off than if you were not wearing
a seat belt at all it had no helmet but
would anyone call that safe drunk
driving